as a dermatologist I don't wear chemical
based sunscreens only mineral based I'm
Ilya with sunscreen safety and this is
a 20 study it's actually been known
since the 90s it just wasn't recognized
by the FDA until recently toxicologists
everywhere else have been taking
absorption into account when working out
safety limits plus they look out a lot
more studies he says applying sunscreen
every day for years could change the
safety yes it can and again it is taken
into account in the safety assessments
he says some chemical sunscreens are
known hormone disruptors this isn't true
with sunscreens on humans according to
the scientific definition of endocrine
disruptors there are effects in animal
studies with unrealistic amounts and
some conflicting biomarker changes in
human studies which is why the eu's
expert panel has been re-examining
potential endocrine disruptors I've gone
through how they do these before they've
looked at four chemical sunscreens so
far there wasn't enough evidence to say
any of them were endocrine disruptors